hi queen with both of you thank you
the movie is so much fun it's funny it's
endearing but what I loved about it the
most was just your friendship you guys
you can see it are you guys on script or
you guys freestyling what we sell a
little bit yeah it was a little bit of
ad-libbing and bringing our real-life
friendship to the ring the screen
because that's what we wanted that's
that was the goal
yeah and this could be it could go work
in the opposite where you have amazing
chemistry with somebody then you're like
wow didn't you know didn't get up there
on the screen
my goal when we thought about Lea doing
this Mayan Jones relationship I was like
oh this is I have a relationship like
this was someone in my real life and
that happens to be Lia if she does this
the goal is just to get our friendship
the heart the soul the brutal honesty
the laughter the support all of it on
the screen if we can do that and every
scene then I know this would be some
special yeah it was it was such a great
experience for me to be able to work
with somebody who I really really trust
me just really yeah I don't do this a
lot like there's my first big major film
so it should be there every day and then
like in a lot of the story yeah yeah so
it was just what yeah but I just didn't
look at like I was like I'm doing a
movie with my friend yeah and it was
just really about doing a movie with my
friend and that's it was amazing if I
could I couldn't have asked for a better
experience
yeah working with your best friend I
mean there's gotta be things that you
love
but then there's got to be like pet
peeves you're like why are you bringing
this to tour today but we do that but
that's that's who we are you know she's
like you're annoying I'm like you're
annoying you know why you be where are
we eating yeah right then like she's on
a diet I'm like we need to go for pizza
yeah having it you know you know but
where it's real it's funny cuz a lot of
what I'm asked is like what are you guys
do together like this friends about what
are you doing with your friends yeah you
know cuz I always like it Marie yeah
weird what I don't know what's it in
like we Susie socks yes with no makeup
hair off down out bye
on ourselves and our yeah and everybody
else in our line and how we're failing
our children you know normal mom stuff
yeah normal mom stuff you guys are
killing me um was there a scene in
particular that was just your favorite
to shoot oh my god I mean there was so
many you know why because a lot of the
scenes all right like we're done I'm
like I took it away those are the Moses
like because I would or in Brooklyn and
one job honestly the kitchen scene where
I blow out the candle yeah you know she
unbuttons her pants as we're taught it
was felt the most real to me and also
tapped into the part of the relationship
that I love so much with Leah whereas I
can let her see my vulnerabilities and
my deepest darkest kind of feelings of
inadequacy at times which we all have
and she just stands there and smiles and
I know I'm not alone that I think wasn't
an amazing thing that we captured it
those are not the scenes that people
talk about right but it's the scenes
that ground the friendship and the movie
that make the movie so real and I
couldn't have done that with anybody
else but Leah and just oh yeah such a
better answer yeah deep and amazing I'm
gonna say that next time and then just
steal it
you